you also had
um a number of very different kinds of
jobs yeah you worked in a you were a
night Watchman in a museum yeah how were
you were you I know I wasn't a night
Watchman I was a security guard I like
saying nightwatch I like the idea okay
of you and you befriend a mouse who's
also you have a really long flashlight
and you guys have Adventures I mean if
you if you don't mind me having that
sure okay I was a night Watchman uh it
was during the day
sure uh uh yeah and uh my you know my
job was basically to like stand there
pretty much and if someone got too close
to the
painting just tell them hey can you back
away and then
that was pretty much it yeah yeah yeah
so you were sort of like uh you were uh
you know someone who was job was to
monitor at a prom an adult YouTube
a little bit pretty well yeah pretty
much hands off the lower back
um that was it yeah I was hoping for
like you know some kind of huge theft of
something would you have done anything
no
no but I would but it would have been
like would you have helped them
no no that edge is dragging that's gonna
hurt the frame I'll get that edge you
get the front
and let's get this van Gogh out of here
there you go guys all right I think we
got it yeah yeah
just keep the bungee cords yeah that's
those are yours to keep
um you worked at a were you at a you
worked at a Starbucks I did I did were
you uh what's what's that giggler uh it
was the best I loved it I was I worked
for a few years
at the Starbucks uh in the Palisades
that's where they put me and I would
draw I remember just driving up there
and sometimes famous people would come
in and you know at the time I was doing
kind of uh comedy for just for fun and
uh uh and Brad Garrett came in one day
that's a very tall man yeah very tall
and he left like a 20 tip and I was like
oh my gosh that was like so cool you
know uh do you think he felt he probably
felt because you recognized him he had
to leave a 20 tip maybe maybe that's the
Trap because I was like that's the Trap
you're in because people go like oh
that's so cool it's Randall Park yeah
and um you know in the old days you
could throw a couple of coins in there
that's right that's right now I gotta
leave twenty dollars every time yeah
yeah I have a thing where I leave 20
but it's on a fishing line oh my God
and so I get they get that initial burst
uh of like Conan it seems like wow at 20
that's pretty good he just you know he
he didn't really get he just got a water
and he gave me a 20. yeah and then I I'm
outside the store and I wait until their
back is turned and I whip the 20 away
and then I watch them accuse others in
the store of stealing it oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I've been using the same 20
since 1993.
I was ordering water it's all over the
country coffee shops all over the
country I don't even want the stuff I'm
ordering there half the time but I I
just want to make a good impression and
then I want my 20 back